la première ministre m'a demandé de
suivre euh et de mieux coordonner les la
lutte contre la drogue dans le domaine
portuaire et au travers d'une commission
qui s'appelle la commission
interministérielle de sûreté portuaire
la
sismap et dans laquelle nous examinons
un certain nombre de dispositifs pour
justement améliorer notre notre
efficacité en matière de de lutte contre
la toxicomanie dans les Pors alors
pourquoi dans les ports parce que la
cocaïne et surtout parce que la première
ministre a voulu que véritablement nous
mettions un coup d'arrêt enfin un coup
d'arrêt que nous puissions au moins
lutter efficacement contre le trafic
dans portuire parce que vous le savez
une grande partie de la cocaïne arrive
malheureusement les ports d'Europe du
Nord qui ont rehaussé leur dispositifs
de protection et il fallait que que nous
puissions réhausser le nôtre alors le
système portuaire en terme de suivi
étatique est assez compliqué puisqu'il y
a à la fois un préfet qui est chargé du
du du suivi de la sûreté que ce sont les
c'est le ministère des Transports au
travers de la DGITM qui a la compétence
en matière de suivi de enfin de tutelle
en matière de suivi des différentes
autorités portuaires quand il s'agit des
grands ports de l'État bien évidemment
je parle pas des ports décentralisés et
nous avons d'autres acteurs dont je
parlais tout à l'heure les douanes
notamment qui interviennent sur le
dispositif portuaire don la donc la
nécessité d'une coordination
interministérielle au travers de cette
sismap euh pour marquer l'intérêt que
que la première ministre porte à ces
sujetsl elle a demandé à son directeur
de cabinet de présider cette sismap ce
qui donne quand même une portée un peu
supérieure au dispositif de comitologie